on parlait justement de ce mouvement de
grève des avocats nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec m adrien mamère avocat et
signataires de cette tribune à peu près
400 avocats bonjour bonjour alors le
conseil national des barreaux a voté
samedi pour la poursuite de la
mobilisation des avocats contre la
réforme des retraites vous irez donc
jusqu'au bout oui on ira jusqu'au bout
je pense que les avocats aussi bien dans
la rue que dans les palais de justice
que à travers l'action par le dépôt de
demandes de mise en liberté massive
qu'on a tenté d'expliquer à ceux qui
nous gouvernent et au ministère de la
justice et au magistrat qui peuvent
certainement l'avoir un peu mal pris ou
penser qu'on cherche à encombrer une
juridiction qu'on chercherait à créer
des vices de procédure sur des délais
non respectés qui pourrait entraîner des
remises en liberté de dangereux
criminels ou de dangereux terroristes
qui sont pour l'instant quand même tous
en détention provisoire est donc présumé
innocent jusqu'à ce qu'il soit déclaré
coupable
je pense que c'est un mouvement qui qui
qui est très suivie et que oui on sera
donc on continuera de se battre à être
dans la rue alors le conseil national
des barreaux ils appellent à une grève
qu'en dire d'absentéisme une grève de ne
pas assurer les permanences de ne pas
recevoir nos clients à nos cabinets de
demander le renvoi des audiences
correctionnelles
je parle pour ce qui me concerne parce
que je suis avocat pénaliste donc au
niveau des avocats civilistes des
avocats en droit social des avocats qui
font du droit des sociétés je sais
absolument pas qu'elle est
leur position mais j'ai l'impression que
c'est un mouvement qui est assez suivi
parce que ce qu'on voit c'est que dans
les projections qu'on a qu'on a pu faire
que certains confrères ont pu faire on
voit très bien que des petits cabinets
dont des cabinets qui vont des avocats
qui vont gagner enfin quitte donc le
bénéfice est en deçà de 40 mille euros
par an vont avoir des cotisations qui
vont quasiment doublé pour une pour une
retraite qui va arriver c'est pour que
les gens comprennent bien vous ne
bénéficiez vous ne bénéficiez pas du
régime universel non plus d'un régime
spécial vous bénéficiez d'un régime
autonome d'accord donc les gens peuvent
vous reprochez votre manque de
solidarité parce que vous ne voulez pas
participer à ce régime solidaires et
j'ai leur mire apparemment ce serait
faux puisque vous êtes excédentaire est
mort vers c'est donc près de 100
millions par an au régime
universellement c'est ce que j'allais
vous dire vous avez vous avez répondu à
ma place non on n'a pas une caisse de
régime autonome et qui est coupé du
monde de nos concitoyens laquelle les
caisses sont excédentaires
elles sont très bien géré et on le le la
caisse nationale des barreaux français
revers ça de ce que je sais moi mais
j'ai pas les chiffres exacts mais on
parle d'une centaine de millions d'euros
par an à la solidarité nationale
alors vous êtes jusqu'au boutisme on
l'avait dit tout à l'heure vous allez
aller jusqu'au bout manifestement le
gouvernement eut aussi quelle peut être
l'issue quand les deux camps paraissent
aussi déterminé écoutez j'ai pas j'ai 37
ans je suis pas comment dire inscrit
dans les luttes sociales depuis ma plus
tendre enfance mais quand même un petit
peu j'ai défilé dans la rue à certaines
occasions jeu ce que je déplore dans le
cadre de la réforme c'est la façon que
le gouvernement à deux de la faire
passer
on a l'impression d'une vraie impression
de passage en force le conseil d'état a
émis un avis qui est très critique sur
la fin le texte en lui même
l'absence de réflexion total l'absence
de l'isi
édité pour tous les constructeurs et
tous les citoyens qui vont en faire
l'objet on a l'impression que ce
gouvernement veut passer coûte que coûte
et complètement sourd aux revendications
qui sont pas que celle des avocats qui
sont celles des personnels médicaux des
salariés des cheminots des enseignants
en toute la france quasiment toute la
france et en contestation face à cette
réforme que le gouvernement veuille
passer coûte que coûte
mais écoutez c'est le gouvernement moi
j'en appelle quelque part au législateur
que le parlement qui est acquis à une
majorité vers celle du gouvernement mais
se réveille et ne laisse pas qui est
qu'un vrai débat à l'assemblée nationale
et peut-être que c'est là que la réforme
passera pas parce que pour l'instant il
faut quand même rappeler qu'on en est au
à l'état de projet de loi voilà c'est
pas encore on en n'est pas mon nom n'est
pas encore un texte définitif on sait le
début c'est le début mais la façon dont
le gouvernement est sourd aux
revendications pour moi est très
inquiétant très inquiétant et jouit j'ai
pas d'autres mots c'est très inquiétant
ça peut rejoindre un peu la doctrine du
maintien de l'ordre en manifestation on
voit que bon il a fallu attendre qui est
un nombre considérable de blessés pour
que on nous annonce hier ou avant-hier
je sais plus que la grenade jlf 4 va
être enfin retirées de l' usage des
forces de police et de gendarmerie enfin
vous voyez c'est ce qui est déplorable
dans ce pays aujourd'hui c'est que on a
un gouvernement qui veut passer coûte
que coûte et qu'il faut qu'il y ait de
la casse des dégâts ou une qu'on arrive
à une sorte de point de non retour pour
que y ait un pas en arrière
voilà en tout cas nous ce qui nous
concerne les avocats les propositions
qui ont été faites pour calmer notre
révolte ne sont absolument pas de nature
à nous satisfaire et on continuera notre
combat pour être entendu dernière
question un très rapide il ne reste pas
beaucoup de temps les avocats sondeurs
vous êtes d'or pour les au cas où pour
tous les français pour tous les avocats
et aussi pour les français
merci m adrien ma merde avocat
signataires de la tribune aux côtés de
très nombreux confrères et pas que des
confrères qui ont des petits cabinets
comme le mien il ya aussi des coudes et
entre guillemets des grosses pointures à
des avocats qui ont pignon sur rue qui
ont signé cette tribune
on a notamment été soutenu par christian
saint palais qui
le président de l'association des
pénalistes et c'est une p tit c'est une
un texte d'une tribune qui a été à
l'initiative notre confrère yves levano
merci beaucoup merci